Magic
magic where are you from originally I'm
from Los Angeles California
South Central so yeah
tell me about your family growing up
um we grew up in a pretty large family
uh my mom had 11 kids uh I grew up in
Jordan projects
well all throughout the project systems
um the housing is uh mixing Gardens and
jerking down and you name it I've been
there
um
uh some the youngest of seven boys
I got
more pigeon fires than anybody in my
family and um
I probably did more time to any of my
brothers
you join the gang early yeah 14 14.
did you feel like there was an option
for you other than that uh yeah I mean I
was into sports and stuff like that but
it was just I never had no Father Figure
to like uh like influence me in or to
coach me or to like you know you had Mom
and Dad uh I have my mom and then um
then she got sick and had a coma and I
went up to
live my auntie which adopted us uh
fairly young me and my little sister my
two brothers your dad your dad wasn't in
the picture no
and you uh
so you joined a gang at 14 what happens
after that
um
pretty much
[Music]
um
it was actually when I started banging
it was fun it was probably about
December of 97.
and everything was
um like
real Metro like like really
um on site uh with with rival games a
lot of a lot of casualties a lot of you
know fatalities a lot of
a lot of blacks
that I grew up with are not here today
um due to you know uh
I'm like luckily I'm lucky enough to
make it through the storm and um and I'm
just I'm just some grateful enough to be
here to make this interview today
because uh
it's been many times where I shouldn't
have been
like a lot of times
how many years do you do in prison I did
my first term ever I got four or eighty
terrorist threats and gbi
and gbi is a great value Andrew
and um
so due to 9 11
um terrorist threat was big and I felt
right under
the when I just changed it from a
low-fat into a higher felony which was
you know the strikable defense so I got
a strike fairly Young
and anybody to be in the prison system
justice so they know once you take your
strike
it's it's pretty much a wrap from there
um
and um I developed my second and I'm on
my third
I have three strikes
so you gotta you gotta walk a very
straight line now uh yes I do
but do I live life like I got three
strikes no I don't
I still live life on the edge I live
like
like it you know but I do know that it's
I got more at stake than other people so
that's probably why I go harder than a
lot of people they do because they
really ain't got no nothing really to
lose and any kind of prison terms so
they can just come back out and start a
fresh again
um by me having three strikes as I'm not
able to do that uh be uh starting to
over fresh it'll be after 15 years and
that's
I'm already 38. that's just if I get
you know if I get another strikable
offense that's uh 5 10 15.
plus the you know whatever time I'll get
for the crime I committee so
it's not like a walk in the park for me
no more when it comes out of law so I
kind of walk a straight line but I walk
a hard straight line like I don't
if I'm gonna do something I'm gonna do
it big if I'm gonna go out if I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go all out you know I don't
care girls no more because I developed a
a sense of feeling that uh I am a gun
you know being that everybody know
what's it gonna go do to you a gun's
gonna kill you and I know exactly what
I'm gonna do uh so I don't need a girl
so all I need to do is get one and
um
but I don't really try to take nothing
that far I've been like that that's why
I don't affiliate myself with uh
black people or say [__]
oh okay
[__] is ignorant and it's different
between
a black person and a [__] of course we
all know that uh uh
[__] is ignorant um who just failed to
realize it's fail to want to um
to understand common knowledge of like
uh this is what you're supposed to know
Common Sense to common courtesy comment
you know it's just like
just so I mean
so I try not to um
you know hang with people like that
engage with people like that uh I hang
with the Mexicans
and um I feel like um
the better alternative for me because uh
dick while the black people at the heart
of downtown I didn't I discovered
downtown until I was like 33 and I'm 38
that was about five years ago when I
came out here I was so devastated I'd
never seen so many black people in my
life I wonder where all the black people
have went and when I came downtown it
was like I was mixed emotion I was like
like
happy I was sad I was [__] everything
bro that was like
that was like out of place and it's like
I called [__] downtown Gotham City
and like you know this is kind of the
statistic of
um of a [__] when um
when Society can't do nothing with them
they got places like him if he ain't in
jail you're down here
and so that's why I started referring
from being down here and try to be in a
more diverse area where I'm still
downtown but not downtown Skid Row
yeah but you're on the street yes I'm on
the street my choice
I'm just dodging responsibility as a
father and a man you have kids yeah so
how many kids I got six kids five baby
mamas
and um
I'm active in some a couple of them life
I'll take like you know get provided and
stuff whatever I come up on off the
streets or whatever but I'm basically on
like a vacation because uh
you know being a part of society you
have to uh be one of those to get up
every day and go to work and to be that
example but
we all know people that's living
that lifestyle basically hate their
lives they got to get up and work a job
that they probably hate just to give
somebody else they check to allow them
to live
you got to pay this man rent after you
just work for it yeah thanks for letting
me live I'm on the streets I'm in a
trailer I have the same instead of
cities that uh you do in the house I
have running water I have light I have
everything and I pay for nothing no
taxes
everything I mean I'm living like tennis
shoes a lavish lifestyle compared to
most people in society
um
you know I'm
like that's the best of the best things
uh you know it's just I don't know what
they cracked up to be they're not about
drugs and and all that it comes along
with it but
it's more than that to that but beats
living in a tent uh of course I mean I
would never I would never uh
if I ever have to push a basket and
recycle it's it's Tap Out times I mean
program or something I mean I cannot
handle it with myself I need help
resources from you know
from the government or some assistance I
mean I can't do it no more whenever I
have to [__] live in a tent that's is
I mean I got points to where I'll never
go lower than what my standards are and
what you know what I'm saying man it'd
be time to do get hard out here but it's
times that I have actually spent more
money than people that work every day
in the harder like in my sometimes I
mean not sometimes but all the time I
get my family stuff
they don't look at me like as a homeless
or I come when I go to my people's house
yeah I was like what you got for me I
always got something good all right man
but trust me like
this I mean even though it's um
it's not uh the way the world and uh not
a good
good example to lead by but
uh made more money that I've made on the
streets and I've worked for kids rooms I
worked for uh warehouses
um you name it as construction all that
and I've never made as much money as I
do now on the streets
um well
well that part is kind of um
well I'm saying like this I don't sell
drugs
and I don't Rob people
but what I do do
is um
uh formulate a team of elite criminals
and uh
and find out their best interests and
their best access and I use it to my
advantage and um what I do is I like to
find a little
like like
cracks and crevices of these companies
that they don't think the public aware
too like maybe a side door or something
like that just or just a rooftop and
very like discreet and very like you
know and um I like to
you know get my uh my
um
my conversations from um I guess these
companies that don't mind uh
you know giving it up because they you
know also with the train thing uh I'm
pretty sure you heard that on the news
uh the train um
um I know people are part of that we had
the best of the best thing from the wall
tools from Milwaukee from household
appliance from everything I everything
you name it I can we got it isn't that a
form of stealing yeah oh that is a form
of stealing but if you look at it it's a
form of of a higher level than like
petty theft and yeah
exactly there's people been knocking off
the trains from the beginning of the
time since the horseback and so that's
always been a scapego for uh criminal
minding people
um and just now just got way more easier
with the due to the uh stopping of
important and Export and important and
escort um
merchandise from China and stuff thanks
to Trump on that um you know he made
that possible for us so what stops you
from just getting a legit legitimate job
um well seeing that um I make more than
um my friends that uh that do work and
the bus they ask and it's kind of like
why would I want to do that it's like
even though maybe I would
people will look at me differently like
how as long as you got money people
gonna look at you the same way whether
you work hard for it or whether you make
it on the street
so trust me it's like
as long as you're making money that's
all the world like needs you to make
money to spend money to give it back to
them I don't care how you make it as
long as you have it
so that's the case I might as well get
it the easiest way
or and the the best way then the most
frequent way is you know but you know I
know it's gonna catch up to me one day
probably
um but
that's if I start um dabbing and stuff
like I said I formulate the team
and then um you know I have them go do
you have a bank account uh well for uh
under the bank account
um
uh Bank houses
um this is what I guess or um I don't
know that's for people with plans and
goals and I don't hardly have no goals
or nothing said I'm not trying to buy a
car a house or nothing no I have a shoe
box yeah yeah and they're like that you
don't pay you don't pay taxes right I
don't pay taxes at all yeah
but is there a drug in your life of
course
uh crack never crystal meth one of them
what's the other one did you think I
don't know looking at your body I would
guess crack but why is cracking my body
because you're lean and
physical you know you you you're built
yeah I've seen a lot of crack bodies
like that that's kind of offensive no I
don't smoke crack I see my parents smoke
crack uh I'll do crack I do
weed
lines of Chris I don't smoke crystals I
do lines
and black enough that's about all of uh
and then being black is a drug out here
is it [__] drug addictive Dangerous
Drug being black so I'm already I was
born harmful and and with some type of
you know I'm saying
so um I just figured like that like
anything that you uh endure in your life
that's not good for you it's just
considerable drug in my case the LAPD
and we will be like uh like
African parents anybody suggested well
anybody that caused the effect anything
that causes an effect in my life to make
me think differently than what I should
is consider it could be a drug it may be
so um
so I'm not really addicted to drugs I'm
addicted to the lifestyle that comes
with the drugs but what is it about this
lifestyle
um
like Freedom Bookoo sex Freedom
definitely Freedom uh you know you don't
you don't have no sense of
responsibility you know
even though I miss being a dad but
man and once this street [__] gets a
little harder than this then I'll maybe
consider going back to my old ways and
working and doing all that but it's
boring until it's boring tell me about
the sex that you're here you just
mentioned oh man Crystal Matheson you're
living on the street oh does that mean
that's a straight make sure for like
you're handsome dude so you're going to
get yes I mean that's why I'll try to
get the best of the best women that's
out on this [__] in the streets because
you know they ain't they deal I mean
they do drugs too so you can't get them
two shout outs so I get the best of the
best women out here
and just all day just non-stops just
like [__] you know that's one of the
side effects of the drugs it uh
stimulates you
um
security
and it can stimulate you your mind to
alter it to whatever moves when you're
in like uh I was like I do a line and I
want to be on a hunt for a girl and then
sometimes I do a line and I want to be
able to hunt for the [__] to owe me
some money it depends on what like level
you on and this is puts you on that
level to a higher like standing and it
makes all your your senses like open
like you know I'm saying you'd be so
like Vigilant and like to what you're
doing like it brainstorms uh way more uh
options than the normal brain which will
be just like you know
no tell me about how crystal meth
enhances your sexual
it does if you have the right to the
right to write you know what I'm saying
connect or whatever stay with some good
[__] it's like as soon as you do a line
because I do long I can't really tell
how they smoke unless you do a line and
it burns and once you get that drip
and you get that drip and it's over that
means it's entering your bloodstream and
he's just doomed and if your mind is on
sex and that's that's what it is and and
it's gonna be like like that until your
mind Venture off to something else but
like if you had a strong mind you can be
[__] for hours like I I [__] for
like two like winning girls I've been
knowing for like 16 years
I've been known for like uh 16 years
when I first started doing Crystal when
it was just like all right it's best
um we [__] for like 12 hours straight
and like the comforter was soaking wet
like you can pick it up and [__]
dress it like this though if like oh my
God I'm never like that was the best
like
in the longest session I ever had and
she still stuck with me to this day like
and she's married and everything and
it's just one of the the perks that the
the the the crystals have
um but if you misuse it or if you let it
do you it could be harmful and
ineffective like um like it [__] up
your um
yeah we're bringing your uh
your sleep schedule yeah yeah so
definitely appearances and all type of
[__] it's just crazy it depends on on
what type of move you in now but how
strong the drug is and this environment
is like a you know this is actually a
party drug it's like it blew Coke by
storm like
I don't I never seen nobody um
do a Coke line and then try Crystal and
go back to Coke never it's like
bro it's like just like we crack uh
crack hit the the people so strong and
hit black people so strong that I got
scared of it I will never ever do try
crack
ever in my life try to crack because of
how addictive it is
and how that you know I'm saying the the
Motions you go behind it and
it was just crazy so Crystal didn't
didn't
you know it didn't
have a wave like that of but now it is
but it's not it's a very popular drug
it's very popular and a lot of
professional people do crystal just to
be on a higher professional level and um
it's a common drug now
I'm not gonna lie um first I was ashamed
of using it and so I seen people that I
looked up to actually using it too so I
was like damn
but um either or it's that's really not
a good thing to do it's just been toxins
in your body but pollution is Toxin also
and we ain't got no choice but to inhale
that
so it's like if I'm like from a dime a
diet do what I want to
yeah but but crystal is uh definitely a
sex drug what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret is for taking my first
strike but for taking my first strike
your first strike you got your prison
time because after that I was just like
a prison Magnum I was a Magnum for jail
I did all my 20s in jail I made that's
why I made my game banking career in
jail not the streets some people do it
on the streets but like if all the real
dancers whoever out there listening we
know that all the real [__] is in jail
um
County May I was feeling me so I'm proud
of that and that's what all that's where
you it's not like you can go run behind
your homies or go run behind nothing no
it's it's there right then there in
front of everybody and he's just a
Persona you got to Bear for the rest of
your life you know I'm saying that's
what made me
um the upgrade my gangsterism as you say
um and at a higher level than a lot of
people that's older than me that's you
know what I'm saying because uh I
learned it from the ones who do it best
so I'm out to um I'm not um really uh
I don't regret going to jail I just
regret taking that strike uh which uh
kind of length is my uh my time other
than the normal with no record like if I
I went to jail for uh
um our
RSP receiving stolen property and I've
seen my homies get out of jail five six
times
for RSP and within the months my first
receiving stolen property bro they try
to offer me five years
so that that's that come along with that
strike that first strike I took I had a
fraud uh the identity
um uh case of identity theft case with
the tap pass because I had a strike
they made me plead to another strike
about uh a strike and five years
probation just because of that and but
anybody else that would have gave him
180 days or just time service something
like that so taking that first strike
was my biggest regret and that kind of
put me downhill my Joker you think
you'll be on the streets the rest of
your life oh no of course no I'm gonna
hang this up one day I'm not gonna be
old out here that's one of my pet peeves
one of my biggest uh
um uh fears has been out here all in
this and just missing out on my uh kids
completely like my oldest kid is 22.
um I guess and then my um my brother
coming son he just made it in high
school and all that so what I'm gonna do
is my plan is to because I wasn't there
for y'all
you can you count me to be there to take
care of my grandkids you know and by
then I'll be I'll be too old and I mean
too old to be running around out here
you know but my dad is still on the
street in the trailer and all that he's
like 73 years old
he's the first of his first member from
his game um he's a highly respected gang
member too and and my mom and aunties
tell me you'll be just like your daddy I
don't even know who the [__] he was who
the [__] is my daddy but well I wanna um
reunited with him when I got older bro
and I see the way he get out and his
gangsterism at a high level they was not
lying I'm just like my daddy it's all
right
um and I consider myself as one of them
ones one of the ones being whoever
running [__] in that area I'm one of
them
yeah I know when I go to jail I'm a rep
that wanna this just happened like that
my leadership is like stupid powerful
when it comes down to uh taking orders
and um just just like
like if I don't run [__] ain't right so
my block I run it
so somebody's gonna ask so I'll ask the
question in the comments um
do you work out no this is just your
natural body yes this is counting Bill
All County Jail in prison calisthenics
when's the last time you spent time in
prison uh stop in prison probably like
um
you're going to the gym every day no I
don't see this is all calisthenics no
weights you know I don't eat like all
that other [__] and I don't drink soda I
drink juice
no no I got diabetes and all that but
you do yeah but you know I'm not about
to let the doctor go diagnose me and
give me all three type of medicines then
I'm gonna start rivering and die and I'm
not about to do that so it wouldn't take
uh total I mean and it gets the best of
me then I'll start doing something about
it but until then [__] it
I'm afraid somebody's gonna pick up
crystal meth after seeing this video
with you you in the tank top uh hey well
just if you do it do it just don't let
it do you that's all I can say because
you'll be a zombie walking around here
with no shoes no it's funny funny of
those yeah for every one of you there's
about five thousand you know
but psychotic zombies yeah but um
that's what it is um
do you moderate how much you no of
course
um of course I'll I have a lemon um I
mean it depends on like I said depending
on how good the drug is because this is
good one lime two lines give me through
the day like through the day like as
soon as that higher coming down another
one then up
on something like for real like and then
but if it's weak then I'll be stuffing
my nose with this [__] and just just it
depends on how good it is is it
does it scare you at all to be
ingesting a drug that is there's so
little regulation on how it's made like
you know yeah you don't know who's
making it sometime it is and especially
deal with the fentanyl uh uh usage and
there's fentanyl just sweeping the
nation and death tolls it does scare me
that I could be slipped uh some uh
something that I can make me balanced
some is not made right but
I think
they got that they got that part figured
out because
um
there's a certain type of person you
have to go through before the drugs
actually hit the streets I've heard that
somebody people describe the ingredients
in crystal methods yes
appliances as you you are correct
but
um
like I said pollution is uh
a little a lot worse than that yeah and
this [__] tap water we're drinking is
probably true yeah so that's true who's
to say and then so many recalls on foods
and so many salmonella poisonous so what
the hell I can be a uh uh the square
that never did nothing and and died from
eating some [__] cabbage with [__]
salmonella you look healthy to me yeah
so it's just I'm taking the risk either
way whether I'm living the normal life
or this life I'm still taking a risks
why
statistics black young male
and so
it's already almost already counted out
before I was counted in so I just yeah
magic what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
uh
uh the most important
um
and I just learned this recently too
if that if
they're not for you they're against you
and that's for anybody that is not truly
by your side and that's not that's not
us including family member friends
everybody they're not for you they're
against you and and I kept this like
you know
11 people that was not for me and it was
affecting me bringing me down as a like
you know as a person like and once I
started just [__] it and [__] them and
all that social relief and I just got
more Bodacious and more [__] like
straightforward and like tell how it is
I know Cutthroat I mean that's my that's
the biggest uh the important most
important thing I learned if that was
the question right yeah you need some
sleep no no not really no you don't
sleep yesterday
thank you so much for sharing your story
all right thank you Mark thanks man